recently I came across a story about a  man in San Diego who was being treated  for an addiction to Google glass an  actual look at that story it's a real  story guys addicted to Google glass well  apparently he was wearing his Google  glass for 18 hours a day and he  experienced severe withdrawal symptoms  when he tried to take them off now  hearing this made me realize that Google  glass addiction is a serious issue so I  decided to do something about it I knew  there must be other Google glass addicts  out there who were suffering in silence  so we gathered Google glass fanatics  from around the country people whose  obsessions were taking over their lives  and straining their relationships and we  brought these glass heads together for a  weekend retreat at a secluded Therapy  Center and then we packed that therapy  center with 30 tons of dynamite  [Music]  thank you I'm a mass murderer  you